-This is a brand-new game.
I've never played this.
And I'm actually dreading it.
It's called
"Piece of Cake Trivia." Okay?
♪ -Piece of Cake Trivia ♪
♪ Piece of Cake Trivia ♪
-Now, our announcer,
Steve Higgins,
is gonna be
our quiz master tonight.
Higgins, let's hear the rules.
-Alright, welcome to
"Piece of Cake Trivia."
In each round,
I'm going to ask you both
the same multiple-choice
question.
For each question, you'll
be given a tray of cupcakes
labeled A, B, or C.
When you each have your answer,
you'll bite into the cupcake
you think is correct.
If you're right,
your cupcake will have
a delicious
creamy-filled center.
If you're wrong, it will have
a gross mystery filling.
[ Laughter ]
The player with the most correct
answers wins "Piece of Cake."
Okay, ready?
Here's the first question.
-Okay.
-Are you ready?
This is called
"Piece of Cake Trivia,"
even though they're cupcakes.
"America's Got Talent" judge
Simon Cowell
has a hugely successful
record label.
Which of the following acts was
never signed by Simon Cowell?
Is it A, One Direction?
B, the Spice Girls?
Or C, Teletubbies?
[ Laughter ]
Hold your cupcakes.
-Alright, I think One Direction,
yes.
Right?
Oh, wait, we can't help
each other, right?
-I say what I think now?
-No, wait. Alright.
On the count of three,
we'll say what we think
'cause I'm trying to think.
Wait, hold on.
-And then you, A, B, or C.
You hold up the cupcakes.
-Teletubbies are -- they're --
that's Australia.
Simon's U.K.
I'm going to say C, Teletubbies.
-Okay.
Sofia, do you have your answer?
-Oh, so I have to say something
different than he said?
-No, you can say the same thing.
-Okay, I'm gonna
say Teletubbies.
-Okay, get your cupcake C.
[ Laughter ]
Can you see cupcake C?
Teletubbies.
-Can you just say "Teletubbies"
for three hours?
-I have it right here.
-Alright.
-Okay, take a bite.
-Alright, C.
Let's see if we're correct.
♪♪
-Are you gonna take a bite?
-Of course. That's the game.
Yes.
Here we go, one, two...
-Okay, take it.
-One, two, three, bite.
Oh!
Delicious, garlic-filled hummus.
[ Laughter ]
The correct answer was
B, the Spice Girls.
[ Laughter ]
Garlic-hummus-filled cupcakes.
Very popular with the kids.
-I mean, who did this?
Who decided this?
-I don't know why.
I don't know why.
I looked at it too,
and it looked like --
-Don't look at it.
Don't look at it.
-Well, it is hummus. Gosh.
-I mean, spitting --
spitting it out is not enough.
[ Laughter ]
-I agree with you.
Did you spit it out too?
I couldn't even see.
-Yeah. It tastes like a salad.
[ Laughter ]
-It taste like
garlic filled hum--
Alright, ready for number two?
-Blech!
-I know. Sorry, Sofia.
What was the correct answer?
-It was the Spice Girls, B.
-Oh, I thought he had
the Spice Girls.
-No.
-Alright.
-And he signed the Teletubbies?
-Yeah.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They're huge.
-He's a genius, Simon Cowell.
-Teletubbies were huge.
-I don't want to
play this anymore.
-[ Laughing ] It's graduation
season for the class of 2021.
The student with the highest GPA
is called the valedictorian.
Second highest is
called the salutatorian.
And the student with the third
highest GPA is called what?
Is it A, historian, B,
stentorian, or C, praetorian?
-[ Gasps ]
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Get your answers --
hold your cupcake --
hold up your cupcake
when you have an answer.
-Hold on, so stentorian?
-Yep.
Historian,
stentorian or praetorian?
-Okay, I think I know that one.
If I know that one,
you have to know that one.
You are American.
[ Laughter ]
-I never heard
stentorian or praetorian.
I never heard it.
-You see?
You have to pick the one
you've never heard.
-Well, also, does that make
me -- Maybe I'm too dumb.
[ Laughter ]
I'm never in the running.
-Go for it.
-I'm gonna say --
-Well, you for sure
were not valedictorian.
-Is everybody ready?
You got your answers?
-Yes.
-You got your answers?
-Historian.
-Take a bite.
-It's stentorian.
It's stentorian.
-Take a bite. We'll see.
♪♪
It was A, historian.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Blech!
-Sofia, you got a cupcake
full of corned beef hash.
[ Audience oohs ]
An American staple for the past
200 years, corned beef hash.
-Sofia, I'm so sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so sorry, Sofia.
I'm so sorry about this.
-I think we're gonna get sick,
Jimmy.
Jimmy, we're gonna get sick.
-No, no, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry about this.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
Let's move on -- question three.
-This week Burger King entered
the fast-food
chicken-sandwich wars.
-Yeah.
-So sad.
In most countries, Burger King
is known as Burger King,
with the notable exception
of Australia.
What is Burger King
called in Australia?
Is it A, Burger Billy, B, King's
Dinner, or C, Hungry Jack's?
Hold up your cupcakes
when you have an answer.
-What is Burger King
called in Australia?
-Yep.
-King's Dinner.
-Go for it.
-Yeah, I say so, too.
I think so.
-Ready? One --
Tell me when you're ready
to bite your cupcake.
-Are you ready, Jimmy?
Which one? I took B.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It's tomato sauce!
It's tomato sauce!
[ Laughter ]
The correct answer was
C, Hungry Jack's.
So close.
[ Laughter ]
So close, Hungry Jack's.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, you hear that sound?
[ Air horn ]
-Are you making -- You're going
to make me hate cake forever!
[ Laughter ]
-Sofia, I am so sorry.
I did the same thing with you.
-Ready?
Alright, this is
the last question.
This one is worth
one billion points.
-A billion dollars?
-A billion points.
[ Laughter ]
-Dollars.
-Colombian pesos?
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
-Are you ready?
Are you guys ready?
Oreo just released their
Olympic-themed Team USA Oreos.
-Ugh, so disgusting.
-With popping candy inside.
-[ Exhales sharply ]
Gosh, hold on a second.
What are you saying?
What? Oreos?
[ Laughter ]
-Which of the following
has never been released
as an Oreo flavor?
-Who cares? Who cares?
-And I really hope --
I really hope
you get this one right.
-I don't care anymore!
-I don't care either!
I don't care!
-Was it A...
-Yes, sure.
-...maple bacon Oreos?
-Yes.
B, filled cupcake Oreos,
or C, hot chicken wing Oreos?
Which one has never been
released as a flavor?
-None of them. Who would make
that kind of atrocity?
[ Laughter ]
-It's a trick question.
It's a trick question
'cause I think
it's what's in our cupcakes.
One's filled cupcake,
one is chicken wings,
and one is maple bacon.
So I think we choose.
This is, like, really, like,
a really dark episode
of "The Tonight Show."
[ Laughter ]
We're choosing
our own punishment.
It's like a "Saw" movie.
They would never, ever do
hot chicken wing Oreos.
-Yeah, of course, that's --
that's the one.
-C.
-Well, then go for C.
-Let's go.
-Alright, ready, everybody?
-Come on, Jimmy, you can do it.
Okay. We can do this
one, two, three part.
-One, two, three.
♪♪
-It's vegemite.
-Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
The hit Australian
dessert topping, vegemite.
-Why does that even exist?
I mean, a cupcake is --
it's a sacrilege.
-It looked like chocolate. What?
-It was vegemite.
It was vegemite.
-What is the correct answer?
-The correct answer was
maple bacon Oreos.
-Ugh. Who was the winner?
-I think Sofia's the winner.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm the winner?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am the winner?
-Thank you to Sofia Vergara.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What did you win?
The new season of
"America's Got Talent"
premieres June 1st on NBC.